Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this footage, we have a variety of objects
that differ in geometry, and the goal is to
place them into this box using an AI.
Sounds simple, right?
This has been solved long, long ago.
However, there is a catch here, which is that
this box is outside of the range of the robot
arm, therefore, it has to throw it in there
with just the right amount of force for it
to end up in this box.
It can perform 500 of these tosses per hour.
Before anyone misunderstands what is going
on in the footage here, it almost seems like
the robot on the left is helping by moving
to where the object would fall after the robot
on the right throws it.
This is not the case.
Here you see a small part of my discussion
with Andy Zeng, the lead author of the paper
where he addresses this.
The results look amazing, and note that this
problem is much harder than most people would
think at first.
In order to perform this, the AI has to understand
how to grasp an object with a given geometry,
in fact, we may grab the same object at a
different side, throw it the same way, and
there would be a great deal of a difference
in the trajectory of this object.
Have a look at this example with the screwdriver.
It also has to take into consideration the
air resistance of a given object as well.
Man, this problem is hard.
As you see here, initially, it cannot even
practice throwing because its reliability
in grasping is quite poor.
However, after 14 hours of training, it achieves
a remarkable accuracy, and to be able to train
for so long, this training table is designed
in a way that when running out of objects,
it can restart itself without human help.
Nice!
To achieve this, we need a lot of training
objects, but not any kind of training objects.
These objects have to be diversified.
As you see here, during training, the box
position enjoys a great variety, and the object
geometry is also well diversified.
Normally, in these experiments, we are looking
to obtain some kind of intelligence.
Intelligence in this case would mean that
the AI truly learned the underlying dynamics
of object throwing, and not just found some
good solutions via trial and error.
A good way to test this would be to give it
an object it has never seen before and see
how its knowledge generalizes to that.
Same with locations.
On the left, you see these boxes marked with
orange, this was the training set, but, later,
it was asked to throw it into the blue boxes,
which is something it has never tried before…and…look!
This is excellent generalization.
Bravo!
You can also see the success probabilities
for grasping and throwing here.
A key idea in this work is that this system
is endowed with a physics-based controller,
which contains the standard equations of linear
projectile motion.
This is simple knowledge from high-school
physics that ignores several key real-life
factors, such as the effect of aerodynamic
drag.
This way, the AI does not have to learn from
scratch and can use these calculations as
an initial guess, and it is tasked with learning
to account for the difference between this
basic equation and real-life trajectories.
In other words, it is given basic physics
and is asked to learn advanced physics by
building on that.
Loving this idea.
A simulation environment was also developed
for this project where one can test the effect
of, for instance, changing the gripper width,
which would be costly and labor-intensive
in the real world.
Of course, these are all free in a software
simulation.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!